tomé algunas capturas del ejercicio de
khan academy sobre intuición de
coeficiente de coloración nos dieron
aquí algunos coeficientes de correlación
y tenemos que emparejar los a los
diferentes diagramas de dispersión que
tenemos aquí en el ejercicio de la
plataforma de khan academy esto nos
permite mover estos coeficientes de
correlación para hacer el emparejamiento
con los distintos diagramas de
dispersión y el punto no es averiguar
cómo hacer el cálculo exacto de estos
eso lo haremos en el futuro pero lo que
queremos es obtener la intuición de lo
que queremos medir entonces bueno la
idea principal de los coeficientes de
correlación es que éstos quieren medir
que también un modelo lineal puede
describir la relación entre dos
variables por ejemplo si yo tengo si yo
tengo bueno de hecho voy a dibujar aquí
unos ejes coordinados aquí tenemos el
eje de la variable y y aquí tenemos el
eje de la variable
entonces digamos que cuando cuando x
está abajo y está abajo cuando x está un
poco arriba ya está un poco arriba
cuando x está un poco más arriba y está
un poco más arriba y cuando x está muy
arriba y está muy arriba a este un
modelo lineal lo describiría muy bien
aquí resulta muy sencillo dibujar una
línea que pasa por estos puntos entonces
algo así tendría una r de 1 r igual a 1
un modelo lineal perfectamente lo
describe y es una correlación positiva
cuando una variable incrementa la otra
también incrementa y cuando una variable
es pequeña la otra variable es pequeña y
viceversa
ahora como se miraría una erre negativa
veamos eso sería una situación en la que
un modelo lineal también funcionaría muy
bien pero aquí cuando una variable sube
la otra baja y viceversa entonces voy a
dibujar nuevamente mis ejes coordenadas
ahí están los ejes coordenadas y voy a
intentar dibujar un conjunto de datos en
los que tendríamos una erre negativa
cuando ya está arriba x está abajo
cuando se baja x sube cuando se baja un
poco más x sube un poco más y una vez
más cuando decrece vemos que x crece y
mientras x crece l decrece entonces se
están moviendo en direcciones opuestas
pero si puedes colocar una línea aquí de
manera muy sencilla lo puedes ver la
línea se miraría algo así así que esto
tendría una r de menos 1
y una r de 0 sería un conjunto de datos
en los que una línea no quedaría muy
bien ese ejemplo en el cual el recibo a
la cero lo haré pequeño entonces una r
de cero se miraría algo así entonces
dibujo los ejes coordenadas lo voy a
dibujar pequeño tal vez tendrías un dato
por aquí otro dato por acá otro aquí y
otro acá otro aquí y otro acá y otro por
acá y bueno aquí aquí me quedo muy bien
organizado pero no necesariamente debe
mirarse así aunque tiene sentido lo que
digo como le harías tú para acomodar una
línea aquí podrías poner una línea así o
una línea así o una línea que que se va
así pero puedes ver que en realidad no
hay un modelo lineal aquí un modelo
lineal aquí no no describe la relación
entre las variables de una manera buena
ajá entonces ya con esto veamos si
podemos abordar estos diagramas de
dispersión ataquemos el problema
y lo que haré es ver si a simple vista
podemos encajar aquí algo parecido a un
modelo lineal hay diferentes métodos
para intentar encajar un modelo lineal a
un conjunto de datos ahora estos son muy
imperfectos nada que ver con los que yo
dibujé para r igual a menos uno y era
igual a uno pero estos estos modelos son
del mundo real así se ven las cosas en
el mundo real y sólo en ocasiones muy
raras en el mundo real las cosas se
alinearían de manera perfecta entonces
bueno para el diagrama de dispersión
si yo intentara acomodar una línea se
miraría algo así
si quisiera minimizar distancias desde
estos puntos a la línea quedaría algo
así
y bueno si logro ver una tendencia de
los datos
si los observas puedes ver que cuando ya
es grande x es pequeño y cuando x es
grande y es pequeño por lo que parece
parece ser que r será negativo r será
una cantidad razonablemente menor que
cero se va aproximando a esto y si
observamos lo que tenemos para elegir
vemos que no sería r igual a 0.65 pues
éste es positivo ni este este también es
positivo así que no usaríamos ninguno de
estos dos y observa que este este casi
no tiene correlación r igual a menos
0.02 éste es muy cercano a cero así que
yo me voy con r igual a menos 0.72 r
igual a menos 0.72 muy bien
ahora quiero que quede claro que si no
me estuvieran dando estos valores elegir
yo no podría simplemente decir así solo
viendo estos puntos del diagrama y sin
hacer ningún cálculo decir que eres
igual a menos 0.72 yo lo estoy basando
en mi intuición de que si es una
correlación negativa y tal parece ser
que el patrón se sigue que cuando ya es
grande x es chico cuando x es grande y
es chico y por eso yo quiero algo que se
aproxime a r igual a menos 1 por eso use
este entonces este ya lo usé ahora vamos
con el diagrama de dispersión p
ah bueno jo parece que el patrón va algo
así
esto no es perfecto pero si acomodó una
línea se miraría algo así parece que la
línea queda bastante bien para algunos
puntos claro no les queda muy bien la
línea pues algunos quedan muy alejados
de ella pero parece una correlación
positiva observa que que cuando ya es
grande
x es un poco más grande y viceversa y
cuando lleva creciendo x también va
creciendo y viceversa entonces este será
positivo y tengo estas dos erres a
elegir no sé cuál de las dos va a ser
puede ser igual a 0.65 o r igual a 0.84
entonces bueno aún no sé cuál de las dos
era igual a 0.65 o ere igual a 0.84
veamos el diagrama de dispersión c ahora
este este diagrama está por todos lados
como puedes ver parece más o menos al
que yo dibujé aquí como se miraría una
línea aquí puedes en realidad imaginarte
lo que sea porque no tiene forma se
miraría algo así o tal vez así o tal vez
una línea se miraría así en realidad no
se sabe parece que estos puntos no
tienen como una dirección digamos o un
patrón en el que yo pueda decir cuando x
crece y crece o decrece no hay un patrón
aquí no hay una correlación por lo tanto
la elección para el diagrama de
dispersión se es es como es muy cercano
al cero entonces era igual a menos 0.02
estoy segura de que esta es la r que le
corresponde de hecho si intentáramos
poner una línea que quedara lo mejor
posible probablemente sería una que
tuviera una pendiente un tanto negativa
como puedes ver entonces bueno se
miraría algo así
nota que aunque yo puse una línea hay
muchos puntos que quedan muy afuera o
muy lejos de la línea entonces un modelo
lineal no queda muy bien en este caso
por lo tanto r es igual a menos 0.02 y
bueno éste ya lo usamos ahora por último
tenemos al diagrama de dispersión de
este diagrama usará una de las dos
correlaciones positivas que tenemos y
tiene sentido pues si parece que hay una
correlación positiva cuando es chico x
es chico cuando ya es grande x es grande
y viceversa entonces podríamos intentar
colocar una línea que se miraría algo
así pero puedes notar que el diagrama ve
es mejor un tanto más exacto ajá puedes
ver que los puntos que queremos que lo
que intentamos encajar no encajan muy
bien pues pues siguen estando muy lejos
de nuestro modelo entonces el modelo no
queda del todo bien por lo que yo diría
que el diagrama b es un mejor encaje es
decir un modelo lineal funciona mejor
para
diagrama para el diagrama de dispersión
ve que para el diagrama de dispersión de
por lo tanto yo le daré la r más grande
al diagrama de dispersión b y la r más
pequeña 0.65 al diagrama de dispersión
de r igual a 0.65 y eso es porque aquí
parece haber un patrón para un modelo
lineal pero quedan varios puntos que no
encajan que quedan muy lejos de nuestro
modelo en el que en el diagrama de
dispersión de que en el caso del
diagrama de dispersión ve aquí hay
algunos que siguen quedando muy afuera
pero observa que estos quedan mucho más
lejos en el diagrama de dispersión de y
ya terminamos